رئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق يكلف رسميا رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق بنيامين
نتنياهو بتشكيل الحكومه مجددا بناء على
توصيات غالبيه نواب البرلمان وبلغ عددهم
64 نائبا
لقد منح الناخبون ثقتا لشخص ولحزب الكود
وكذلك للاحزاب الشريكه معنا لكن اريد ان
اقول اعتزموا ان اكون رئيسا وزراء للجميع
لاولئك الذين انتخبوني واولئك الذين لم
ينتخبوني انه ليس مجرد كلام يقال في مثل
هذه المناسبات بل انه يعكس ما يؤمن به في
اعماق ويعكس ما يوجه افعاله هذه هي
مسؤوليتي كرئيسي وزراء لاسرائيل وتحدث عن
نتنياه عن الحاجه للحفاظ على الحقوق
المدنيه الكامله لكل مواطن وتطرق الى ما
وصفه بالارهاب الايراني وضروره التصرف
بحزم تجاهها واحباط جهوده فاللوحيب
الاسلحه النوويه كان نتنياهو تصدر
الانتخابات التشريعيه الاسرائيليه التي
جرت مؤخرا مع حلفائه في اليمين المتطرف
فقد حصل حزب اللكود برئاسته على 32 مقعدا
فيما حصل الحزبان المتدينان المتشددان
لهده وترالي يهودي الاشكناسي الغربيين
وحزب شاس لليهود الشرقيين السفرديم على 18
مقعدا كما حصل تحالف اليمين المتطرف
الصهيونيه الدينيه على 14 مقعدا نتنياهو
المتهم بقضايا فساد تتعلق بخيانه الامانه
والرشوه وهو ينفي هذه التهم بدا عمليا منذ
الجمعه الماضيه مفاوضات مع حلفائه من
اليمين المتدين واليمين المتطرف لتشكيل
حكومه يرجع ان تكون الاكثر يمينيه في
تاريخ اسرائيل